so here's the problem with the girls
that re-wait until they're married to
have sex these girls typically go
through party phase hoe phase
and then conveniently right when they're
looking for a husband
they
find god and the issue with this is it
is a mating strategy that women use so
essentially what's valuable to a guy is
a girl that hasn't slept with as many
people and this girl is trying to
increase her value
without actually adding any extra value
typically the problem with this is that
the second guy that she picks she's just
not as attracted to so he's gotta wait
until they're married because she's just
not as attracted to him it's not as
enticing so to speak so a lot of these
guys end up
with a girl that really doesn't like
them like that and isn't like genuinely
attracted to them and you're not holding
women accountable because you're saying
oh you can do whatever you want and
you'll still have a husband waiting for
you at the end it's just not the case
for a lot of women so let me know in the
comments what you guys think and don't
forget to subscribe to